welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 18
and we're gonna learn how you can learn
like a billionaire
enjoy
[Music]
i think that the way that we currently
do education is is wrong and
and we're when you see something like
the khan academy and so forth
that's probably going in the right
direction i mean generally you want
education to be like
as close to a video game as possible
like a good video game like
you do not need to tell your kid to play
video games
they will play video games on autopilot
all day
so if you can make it interactive and
engaging
uh then then you can make education
far more compelling and far easier to do
so i think that's how it should be and
it shouldn't be that you've got like
these grades where people move in
lockstep
um and so everyone goes through you know
goes like normally
you will go through english math
science and so forth from like fifth
grade to sixth grade to seventh grade
like it's an assembly line
but but people are not objects on an
assembly line
that's a ridiculous notion
people learn and are interested in
different things at different paces
so you really want to um disconnect the
whole grade level three
thing from the subjects allow people to
progress
at the fastest pace that they can or are
interested in in each subject
there's this culture in silicon valley
that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting
a startup and my goal
when i realized that i had a company was
to get it to be
a good company as quickly as possible
where i didn't kind of get out of what
you'd call the like risky
startup phase where you are just like
constantly about to die
and where you could get to a point where
you can actually do some interesting
things and make make a lot of more
interesting bets
and um so i don't know i never read a
lot of the literature on this and i mean
maybe if i had then i would have made so
many mistakes
but so i don't know if like if learning
for me is the right way to go on this
but
i mean but it did i think your model
must have come from somewhere though
even if it was
even if you it was unintentional right
like were you influenced by peter thiel
or sean well yes there was people seeing
all these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before
i'm talking about yeah right yeah but he
was massively influential on my thinking
right i mean
like a lot of the uh the early lessons
that i took
on how to think about strategy came from
peter and sean and
um i did pay a lot of attention when i
was growing up to microsoft i thought
i mean i grew up you know using you know
windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and i
just thought that those were like
the most unbelievable things and in that
sense they are
yeah they really were awesome right um
well i i don't know if you you meant
that positive positively but
i did um and and i thought you know
building this ecosystem was really neat
and that kind of inspired me right
in the way that they built a platform i
kind of thought okay well maybe one day
you know that the tools that i'm
building can be part of a broader
ecosystem as well
so many things go wrong when you're
starting a company and often i think
people
ask you know what mistakes should you
avoid making
and you know my answer to that question
is don't even bother trying to avoid
mistakes because you're going to make
tons of mistakes
right and the the um the important thing
is actually learning quickly
from whatever mistakes you make and not
giving up right and
i mean there are things every single
year of facebook's existence that could
have killed us or made it so that
it just seemed like moving forward and
making a lot of progress just seemed
intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and um nothing is impossible you
just have to kind of
keep running through the walls i would
say reading
is the strongest signal
for success in the future that i've ever
seen it is the strongest strongest
strongest
i got my first job in radio uh when i
was 16 years old
because i've been broadcasting since i
was 16 years old but my first job i got
because i was a great
reader when you are a great reader you
can articulate
and speak and command the english
language in ways that other people
cannot
and people think you're a lot smarter
than you are lots of times because
you're a great reader have you ever met
a person who was a
great reader when they were young who
was not successful
you never never it is the absolute best
foundation
ever in life you cannot invent and
pioneer
if you cannot accept failure to
to invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know
in advance that it's going to work it is
not an experiment and so that's a very
important thing you you know it's
they are inseparable twins failure and
invention so
you have to be willing to do that and
it's embarrassing to fail
um you know it's always embarrassing to
fail but you have to say no
that's not how this works if i said to
you you have a 10
chance of a with a particular decision a
10
chance of a 100 x return you should take
that bet
every time but you're still going to be
wrong 9 out of 10 times and it's going
to feel bad 9 or 10 times
and in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed the
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation
you know everybody knows that if you
swing for the fences you hit more home
runs but you also strike out more
but with baseball that analogy doesn't
go far enough because with baseball
no matter how well you connect with the
ball you can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs
but in business every once in a while
you step up to the plate
and you hit the ball so hard you get a
thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff
and you know one up one at back can get
you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more
it's also better for your customers
customers like the
successful experiments certainly during
the time i was at harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was unbelievable
that became more
obvious during the three-year period i
was here
uh but my dad had been a lawyer i
thought of mathematics
you know like doing well in the putnam
that was the coolest thing uh
and the computer software i didn't think
those
people were as smart as the math people
so it's like well
am i going to go into the easy field uh
or this really hard field but
anyway math uh was fantastic when i
finally picked
and decided to go go do microsoft then i
got into a period
from age 19
to about 40 where i wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or
how mitochondria work i was pretty
monomaniacal
and when i was able to ask steve this is
the year 2000 c balmer
uh he he mistakenly graduated
uh but then he started it stan
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine
but then he started at stanford business
school
and he was in his first year and i
thought this is perfect i'll get him to
drop out of
stanford business school so in a certain
sense he is a dropout uh
and he was very key to the success of
microsoft i mean
uh he knew a lot of things but during
that period i didn't get to do much
at harvard you know i took all these
courses because
it was just so amazing that people were
interested in talking about them
and uh i i have to say
i never went to a lecture during reading
period or any anything because the
courses that i was actually signed up
for i finally started
to work on those uh so i was in halal
the minute would open
to the minute would close during reading
period trying to catch up on
on that other set of courses so people
say i'm a dropout which
is literally true but
because i like college courses the
online
college courses there's a company called
the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
you know at least four or five courses a
year
in a sense i like going to college more
than anyone
so i've sort of made sure my job
certainly post microsoft that i get to
spend my time meeting with scientists
learning new things you know seeing what
the hard problems are
in some cases giving money to people to
take on uh
those very very hard problems i should
mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at columbia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than
any other uh student i i lived there
practically
but you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look
learn more about this because i learned
this over here that changed my whole
life
you know we own geico now because of
that librarian directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that
it's the chance i i i read about
one-fifth the pace that bill does but i
still spend five or six hours a day
reading i mean it's just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people
have been seeing so extraordinary the
lessons and the
you know the discouragements they face
just everything about it so i just
you can't get enough of reading now i'm
going through and teaching myself neural
networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because ai is going to have more of an
impact
than the internet did ai plus new types
of chipsets
plus 5g is going to change things far
more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sep
segregate and separate the [ __ ]
right is as important because
every email you all are about to send me
is going to say
i have this ai solution and we're using
algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work
if i didn't sit down and do the aws
machine learning tutorials if i didn't
go on youtube and take
you know the nyu introduction to neural
networks or whatever
i'm not going to know it i'm not going
to be able to apply it and i'm not going
to be able to be
first and that's fun that's fun knowing
i get to kick the ass to some 22 year
old nyu
graduate that's awesome you know the
first question you're going to get asked
when you go to
apply for a job whether it's now or some
point in the future
is what did you learn what did you do
what skills did you add during the
pandemic of 2020
and i think it's imperative to anybody
looking to
to get a job to really push themselves
forward
to do better than their parents to
really place a focus on learning
you know i i think you'd agree mike and
anybody watching that one of the
greatest skills that we all can have
in the in the business world is a thirst
for knowledge just being excited about
learning
and knowing how to learn and this really
is the best opportunity
ever for people to add to their skills
whether it's taking a coursera class
or you know in the past i would have
said reading a lot of books but now
having learned from my kids
going on youtube and you know watching
uh tutorials and watching videos on
various
subjects you know i learned how to write
a three-letter three-layer javascript
neural network on youtube
and so there's a unique opportunity now
for you to add skills
particularly in areas like artificial
intelligence that are going to be in
great demand that most people have not
yet learned because
you know it's it's so recent that it's
become really applicable
the winner in ai controls the world
china puts together a future plan
saying you know whoever dominates an ai
and they're subsidizing
you know tencent alibaba et cetera
yeah right and that's right they're
they're that's they know it's a race
it is a race we cut our office of
technology and science
to one person who was an assistant to
peter thiel
that's where we stand so when we talk
about infrastructure jobs
you know robots are built in germany and
they're getting buyed by chinese
companies in some respects and i think
some japanese companies bought as well
we don't build robots here very well
right i just invested in my first
robotics company
high robotics that puts robots into
companies um they're in
kansas city i think it is now um but
they
they lease and rent and sell robots into
all these different types of
circumstances to
replace people right but i had to learn
i'm not saying it's a good thing or a
bad thing it's going to happen with or
without me
but i wanted to learn what was going on
those building up
a robotics industry here
investing in our ai industry here that's
the new infrastructure yeah because if
we don't do it and china or russia win
those wars
we're sol right we're out of luck right
and so when we talk about the price of
assets going up
when if you're hiring you know if you're
talking about intellectual assets if
you're hiring like we were just saying
the price is skyrocketing people you
know montreal has become
the the center of the universe for
computer vision um it's not us-based
schools that are dominating
any longer in those areas we've got a
lot of smart kids in mit
all different schools right and kids are
starting to realize it's a place for
them to go
and i'm out there telling people the
first trillionaire is going to come from
somebody who who comes up with something
really unique
in ai today the 18 founders of alibaba a
lot of people
think they are legendary something wow
you alibaba founders you must be
super good at honestly most
of us cannot find the jobs early days
we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a you know a
great university
um but the thing is that we are ready to
learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we will learn with improve
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about
that you will be vp vice president right
you will always be a tiny manager in
your life
because if we're successful people will
hide they will be smarter than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
and you will be happy because this is
the mission that we have
so i would say there's no best
people in the world that is suit ready
for you
the best people is always you you find
the right people
working together training him developing
him
and he training you he develop if then
you have a chance to build a team we
faced a lot of
challenges but i'm sure alibaba is going
to face
more challenges we worry every day
when i was young when company was young
we thought well
what if when alibaba become that big
my life would be easier then now the
companies that
the bigger the company the more problems
i have
so why you are still small company
enjoy it you will never experience
the happiness of operating a small
company
any life we're going to be too big you
have so much headaches
so many things happening and people say
jack you know there are a lot of books
about you
but there's none of the books i write
myself if there's one book i want to
write
in the future it's called alibaba 1001
mistakes
we made so many mistakes
we had so many troubles believing or not
china build up e-commerce company
build up company
no internet connection at that time
no v no no credit cards
no delivery system it's
so we make we meet problems all the time
it's not easy but we tell ourselves
we will be successful until we make 10
000 mistakes
we will be successful if we survive in
any crisis
so when crisis came we know it's a
challenge
everybody start to be united
we solve the challenge then we complete
each other
before we solve the problem of the
crisis
we should not complain so
i have a problem in in hr i have a
problem in financing i have a problem in
technology i have a problem everywhere
tell me so that's why i i become a
mentor
in entrepreneurs uh program in china
people a lot of entrepreneurs have
crashing when i listen to their
questions
oh my god i have this problem too so
i would say we have gone through almost
almost
nine more than 90 percent of the
problems
that any entrepreneur 90 of the problems
that any entrepreneurs have met this is
what we feel
proud at the end of the day i'm going to
tell my kids my grandchildren
it's not the thing we feel proud we
we made alibaba it's so many mistakes
that we overcome so many challenges
we experienced that make me feel proud
life is about experience
so when you become entrepreneur don't
worry about the competitors
don't worry about the mistakes don't
worry about the challenges
go through it that's the great fun part
of your business of your experience and
then
you got a courage you got a wisdom you
got a team follow you
whatever your field volunteer to take on
some new assignments even if they are
outside your comfort zone
take the initiative on your own to learn
and develop new skills
and to build contacts with people who
can help you down the road
when you when you have learned enough
let me put it this way
i know of no nobel prize winner who has
stopped studying
and the in in the information economy
everyone
in both white collar and blue collar
jobs will have to keep deepening their
knowledge
and adapting to technological change
assembling a crew of people who are very
smart
very fast learners was kind of the key
to a success in a startup
as opposed to trying to get someone who
had you know if they had 10 years
experience doing something that's great
but the more fundamental characteristic
is would they learn
fast on the new problems and the new
challenges yeah it's it always feels
wrong to be
anti-experienced but the uh the place
where
can backfires if the experience makes
you think that you know everything
yes and so it's again uh it's important
to know things and it's important to be
open to learning more
and in theory experience is a plus
in practice it's often uh often a bit of
a minus
because people are less open to learning
new things
or they're more set on doing a
particular job in the context of a
startup which is always very tricky
where you have small numbers of people
and people need to be very flexible
about the roles and the roles change as
the company
gets built wisdom acquisition was a
moral duty
it's not something you do just
to advance in life wisdom acquisition is
a moral duty
and and there's a corollary to that
proposition which is very important
it means that you're hooked for lifetime
learning
and without lifetime learning you people
are not going to do very well
you are not going to get very far in
life based on what you already know
you're going to advance in life by what
you're going to learn
after you leave here if you take
berkshire
hathaway which is certainly one of the
best regarded
corporations in the world and it may
have the best
invest long-term investment record in
the entire history of civilization
the skill that got berkshire through one
decade
would not have sufficed to get it
through the next decade with the
achievements made
without warren buffett being a learning
machine
continuous learning machine the record
would have been
absolutely impossible the same is true
at lower
walks of life i constantly see
people rise in life who were not the
smartest
sometimes not even the most diligent but
they are learning machines they go to
bed
every night a little wiser than they
were when they got up
and boy does that habit help
particularly when you have a long
run ahead of you people should be
studying the most successful companies
in the world
not not individuals don't worry about
dave or gary or tony or grant
what are successful people doing you
know i
one of the biggest mistakes i've made in
my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
so what like like like i made so many
dumb ass decisions because uh dave did
it
or the millionaire next door that book
i don't want to be the millionaire next
door i want to know what jeff bezos is
doing i want to know what the boys at
google are doing
okay why why does a guy like mark
zuckerberg
go from college dorm room to one of the
richest
people on the planet that's who we
should be studying
and and don't listen to everybody else
because
those people have financial freedom to
the point to where they they can do
anything they want like you cannot mess
up
some of these people's situation they
couldn't screw it up if they wanted to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need scale your business
so you can walk away from it and money
never stops taking care of you and your
family you don't need to study
27 different words you study one more
and you're probably going to be good
most of us because of instagram and
facebook and youtube
we're listening to so many different
people
that that people do nothing this this is
a new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting
so if you listen to dave dave says buy a
house then you listen to grant grant
says that's stupid
you're not going to do anything and if
you're never going to buy any real
estate hey go ahead and buy one house
yeah you're going to regret it later and
you're going to be like i wish i had
done what cardone said
but but you got to do something and what
you don't want to do is listen
to god and the devil because then you
get stuck in purgatory and you don't
have any fun at all
training if you're not going to train
then put a sign on your desk i quit
learning a long time ago and see how
many people want to buy from
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids i quit learning
i quit reading i quit studying i quit
training i can't get any better
put on there done i'm finished i'm in
retirement early i'm going to purgatory
i'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now i know you know this you've heard it
i hate to tell you this
my boy mcgregor connor conor mcgregor or
mcgregor
my boy conor mcgregor okay i went and
saw him fight in new york i went and saw
him fight for one reason
because i saw him say i'm not the best
this isn't about talent
it's cause i'm obsessed i out train
everyone else i have to win
so bad i train look if you're not
training that says something about your
obsession or
lack of obsession with winning i want
you to win
i know your your wife or your husband
your spouse your family members your
kids
your mom and dad want you to win at the
next level no matter what they tell you
even if they tell you you're doing great
pat you in the back you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win
is to read the only way to win is to
learn learn more
listen more learn something new look
we're in a we're in a time like we've
never been before
technologies come and go faster than
people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or
or short videos or videos that disappear
or videos that say
or text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which i've been
using a lot look the world's changing
and if you're saying to yourself i'm too
old to learn that well then guess what
you're too old to learn that
if you can't learn anything new just put
i'm ripe
and i'm about to fall off the tree and
nobody's gonna want me
look man you gotta train every single
day like your life depends on it
train every single day i am here today
i own these four companies that i own
the studio my reputation
everything is because when i was 25
years old to when i was 30 years old
every single day i trained watching
video
every day i'd watch the video i'd walk
in and then i would role play and then
we would do a sales meeting
every single day explain how you went
from
a salesman who was in it and hated it
yeah to then you know you moved on and
became self-employed and then you were
speaking about sales and you're like a
sales expert so that's what
20 years in between or 10 years yeah no
there was uh there was maybe uh 25
by the time i'm 26 i'm the top one
percent of
all salespeople in the auto industry i
didn't really know what that meant
but but it was important to me that i
was very good at what i was doing now
now now i was in i
i went from hating a job in car sales i
remember going out with this girl and
she said
what are you doing i said i'm a car
salesman and she got that look on her
face like oh my god
that's worse than a man yeah you know i
mean
and and and i had this terrible thing
i'm like okay i'm going to get great at
it
i started studying sales every day i
started recording interviews like
literally you'd come in to buy a car
from me and and i hired my mom my mom
was 70 years old at the time and i hired
my mom and i said you sit over there and
you take
notes really and watch her watch when i
lose her watch what happens then we're
going to
debrief at the end of the deal and i'm
going to see what's working and what's
not i'm recording myself
videoing myself i'm using every little
piece of technology 30 years ago
i came to find out what am i doing right
what am i doing wrong and
what i was doing i didn't know it then
but i was basically codifying sales
i was learning what does it mean when i
say i'm gonna think about it
when is that real when is it not what
does it mean when it says the price is
too high when's that real when it's not
and i started codifying and writing
taking notes keeping all this
information i didn't know this would
happen but
five years later i'm out on the road
knocking on doors
uh selling a a new way to sell things
i'm going to save money this is what you
hear if you look on the internet how do
i make money
first thing you got to do is you got to
save money what do you hear the
politician say the middle class
i'm here to save it what if there is no
middle class and it was just made up
to keep the people civil see
see that that's how you're going to play
this game you got to be available
people have to know you don't talk to
strangers
strangers got everything you want man
everything you want a stranger's got it
your friends ain't got nothing
right if it's up to your friends you're
done
you're like oh my friends are broke i'm
25 years old everybody around me was
broke okay
my mama was scared every time my mama
tuesday tuesday she's clipping coupons
that was the reason to get the newspaper
the coupons are coming she would sit
there and clip a man she had him in the
little box i learned that for you for 16
years i watched my mom do that
for 16 years my mom would tell me hey
grant turn those lights off turn those
lights off
me and my twin brother turn those lights
off from across the house
she could hear me walk out of my bedroom
75 feet away and say turn those damn
lights off
i told you okay twin brothers okay i'm
16 years old my twin brother
my mom said when you guys go pee do it
together
saves water saves water right
okay when my mom fed me because mama i
had a great mom
how many of you had great parents give
you give your parents a great hand huh
dude hey just because they were great
parents doesn't mean they weren't
confused
right because my mama was confused man
my mom did not know how to make money
she had no education she had no ability
she had never held a job she did not
know how to get money
so what she had to do was protect the
little bit of money she had
sell or be sold she was sold on
conservation
reduce risk don't spend contract protect
it defend it
you understand diversify have a lot of
little bets all over the place okay
lots of little bets you should never
have a lot of bets all over the place
until you're extremely wealthy
when you're trying to get wealthy you
want to literally you want to go all in
and it not be a vet you need to know the
space so well
that you're like i know for sure this is
going to work what do you know will pay
you
every time for sure
you first get rid of the little think
and the old ideas and the middle class
mentality
[Music]
i'm gonna go to work i'm gonna save some
money i'm gonna put it in the bank i'm
gonna give it to the man
what's the bank dude the bank doesn't
even keep your money
they hate money cash is
it's trash cash is garbage it's pieces
the garbage paper
it is only useful when it is used
if you're taking notes they didn't teach
you this in school
this has been taught basic fifth grade
sixth grade
not in not when in high school or
college
cash this is a piece of paper okay it is
a piece of paper it's worthless
this is a piece of paper this actually
has more value
this piece of paper right here has more
value than this piece of paper right
here
why because one person has this piece of
paper
2 000 people have this data you
understand
this piece of paper right here is
useless though until it is used
i walked into marlin stadium i was
telling kevin i said goddamn this
beautiful
beautiful how many people does it see
about 30 000 28 29
000. i'm like yeah but y'all never had
that many people here
and they said yeah joel osteen was here
joel osteen had 28 thousand people i
said i'll take the whole place if joel
can do it i can do it
okay if joe can do it i can do it right
we were there five minutes i said i'll
take the place
and they're like when do you want it let
me see if it's available i said i
guarantee it's available
and they're like how do you know that
you don't know our schedule i said i
guarantee you
i guarantee you it's available when i
want it
and um when do you want it super bowl
weekend
they're like yeah it is available
because nobody would do an event on
super bowl weekend
now if you can understand why i did that
event because my entire staff including
jared right here
everyone everyone involved in this event
said do not
do super bowl weekend why would i do
super bowl weekend
i'm the only person other than the super
bowl doing an event
there's nobody else doing an event
there's nobody else doing an event
everybody was worried about the super
bowl dude i just took out the super bowl
took out everybody it got rid of
everybody
number one number two if i pull it off
if i pull it off my brand will be lifted
up
into the heavens as something mystical
yes
okay amen so so sometimes sometimes you
don't do things we made less money on
that event
with 35 000 people than an event with 10
000 but the brand lift
was so unbelievable okay like
the goal was hey jared every day jared
and i were talking
hey jared if we can pull this off it
wasn't about the money
we pulled this off dude it's a game
changer for the brand okay
number one nobody's ever done this 35
000 people super bowl weekend the story
is unbelievable
we we will have pulled it off ourselves
and and
and every time somebody does an event
after this it'll be like
tony does an event with
30 000 people yeah but cardone did 35
000. yes
you understand so you want you want to
pick up
you want to pick up residual from other
people you want to pick up reminders
okay if you can figure out how to use
your competition if they're competition
or
collaborate with them either way you you
want to
have their efforts reminding the public
that's similar of yeah but free
advertising
i spent five years in college i went to
college because i wanted
i thought the teachers were going to
teach me business
i love teachers okay teachers are great
people but
you can't know business
if you're in a classroom it's just it's
just not possible it's like
my economics my economics teacher
uh there there's no way he could imagine
the the the fuel bill on my plane it's
just not real
you go to lord sugar and say hey how do
you make sense of four jets
why would you do that why'd you buy that
building right there that's the
information i want see but
see but most us in this room we were
taught we had to go
someplace and spend four or five years
there i'm not trying to talk you out of
school or university
but the fact that it takes four years to
get out of university by itself is it
is a major problem it's a major problem
you know why
the four years i'm trading time for
money
what do rich people do they trade money
for time
my dad died when i was 10 years old i
had an older brother die when i was 20.
by the time i was 21 years old i was
jaded
and just figured hey life is not going
to last very long
and so somewhere from when
before my dad died to 21 years old
in between there i thought i was going
to be a businessman one day i thought i
was going to be rich and successful
and james bond like i had all these
ideas like when you're a kid you have
all these big giant ideas
and then life starts lost
dad lost brother girlfriend lose her
like i start accumulating all these
losses
start using drugs and alcohol start
using them every day
start making bad choices
25 years old i was broke
i was in debt couldn't keep a
relationship
had no no chance of being married or
having
kids it was impossible right it was just
none of that was even possible and and
and
so so i started putting my life back
together but it's really
to throughout the period from 25 to
today 35 years now
of me studying people that are
successful that has given me the
discipline
and the encouragement along the way
with some milestones like 2008 when the
economy collapsed
that was a that was a huge awakening for
me
getting married another monster
awakening like it gave me another reason
to be
have a purpose being a good role model
for my kids
not just talking the talk but being
someone my kids could look up to and
said that
that's what success looks like just
having money
just having a couple million dollars
if you're not making a difference that's
that that's one level of success
but for kids they don't care how much
money you have
my kids don't they they don't know that
well what what a what does 167 million
in cash look like in an account i
remember when a billionaire showed me
his cash account i was like whoa
400 million dollars sitting in one
account i'm like my god
i literally couldn't read the numbers my
kids don't even care
what my kids do care about what changes
children and what changes
friends and what changes your neighbor
is what they see you doing every day
and it just so happens it takes money to
do things
to fly across the world to make new
friends to create new charities
yeah you know to market to advertise etc
i made the mistake in my life of
studying people that
appeared to be successful a lot of
people are like that
they appeared to be successful you know
today today in the the
the the times that we live in you know
you can go on instagram it looks like
looks like everybody owns a ferrari
everybody has a rolls royce everybody
looks like they're having the best day
of their life that's that's not studying
that's watching
i want to study people or even even at
conferences you can go to a conference
and watch somebody on stage
and he couldn't he he or she could
present to like they're so successful
but
if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot of talking
and so i would just strongly suggest to
people to
pick a handful of people and make sure
those people are actually doing
not just saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day
and how would you know what they're
doing well you should you would you
would see it in their statistics right
like there's some things you can't fake
yeah you can't fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million worth of
real estate this month
with my money hard to fake that okay
it's a great instagram post by the way
but you can't fake it there's going to
be a loan
there's going to be a building there's
going to be you know acres and acres of
land there's going to be
people living there like you just can't
fake it so there's a lot of things you
can fake
you know you can make a nice little
quote put it on instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and
the public is is confused with a lot of
what appears to be the truth that's not
that's right and so i would just tell
people
um study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing i would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them
lines up with where you need advice
right so
warren buffett you know warren buffett
he he's at the
he's at the he's at the tail um
he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it
he doesn't buy stocks he buys companies
yeah
so you got to you got to listen to
people steve jobs right here was one of
the most aggressive
business people that this plan has ever
seen i mean he was barbarian aggressive
so was bill gates
but if you talk to bill gates today bill
and steve steve's not alive obviously
but
bill gates today saying dude i'm giving
all my money away money doesn't matter
that's not what he was saying right here
let's talk about when you started
working for yourself because you know
most small businesses fail in the first
few years
one to three years yeah that most don't
make it yeah i mean there's a lot a lot
of different
numbers out there about that like 50 of
all businesses fail after
about by seven years the truth is they
were failing in the first six months
okay what do you think they did wrong
they don't know how to sell anything i
mean you go to harvard yale or mit
they're gonna if you do studies
oh the reason they were under
capitalized okay look this is completely
ridiculous what they're telling you okay
you don't
you don't capitalize a business and then
run out of money
that's not how you do a business right
this is how wall street does a business
they rip people off they basically go
most most companies developed by wall
street or in silicon valley are complete
ripoffs of the investors
you hear about the netflix that made it
it might not still make it
it's still a negative cash flow business
because they don't know how to sell
their products fast enough
in quantities big enough and it prices
high enough
to basically fund the future so
businesses fail for one reason and one
reason only
because you can't sell your products
fast enough
in quantity is great enough and it
prices high enough
to sustain the business thus harvard
says oh they ran out of capital
yeah why because they didn't sell their
products
so if you can sell products fast enough
quantity is great enough google
google is a company you don't consider a
sales company google
sells products in quantities that are
giant
yeah it profits margins that are high
enough
i'm a student of observation i i observe
things i remember being
being selling cars saying this is stupid
first i learned how to do it right the
customer the 12 steps
right and then i'm like if i do 12 steps
with everybody i can't get 30 units a
month
and then i'm like i started skipping
steps right
uh i mean because i wanted i wanted
those ten car car weeks
and the only way to do that was walk out
there and just start offering people
what they had
what they what they were going to ask me
for anyway right
can i get you a price a payment a down
payment a monthly bank can i get you
everything you need
right i knew it was just a matter of
about 30 seconds they were going to ask
for it all
no doubt so i just basically intercepted
the customer
sped up the processes and and then i'm
like man i started hitting 30 36 units
31 units in 14 days i'm like this is the
way to do it
and then when i lost my job because the
dealer wasn't big enough
didn't think big enough himself didn't
10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
um i went out and started teaching that
nobody ever taught me when i was going
to school
17 years of school nobody ever said hey
maybe you want to stack up some
experiences
and then what happens is kids rather
than going to college what they do today
is
they'll go travel for for a year
what you got to flip it go get your work
ethic in
bank some money make some money i'm
gonna do this left-handed
make some money and then go on the trip
of your life
oh left-handed i'm so good i'm so good
at
everything you got to have confidence
man
so look look look and by the confidence
comes from doing stuff because it
comes from doing business not from
traveling right
like i know people that traveled when
they were young and then they go back
into the workplace in the business place
and they're like
i don't have any confidence in business
you want to have confidence in business
confidence and money confidence with
your family
confidence that you can go places and
look money might not make you happy
i know some of you believe that but
it gives you the security to go where
you want do what you want and stay as
long as you want
if you can get that money right before
you diversify go
go bang on another door yeah you need to
become the freaking
door doorbanging of the universe
so i want to talk about that right
because can i use that word here
you need to become like you need to go
yeah you need to go bang on the door
they tell you to get out of the
neighborhood and you go
figure out how to bang on it again and
not get arrested yeah
like if you can figure that gig out i
guarantee you you will be the most
successful person
your genetic code has ever generated
yeah anyone in your family everybody i
know says man
learn how to cold call i i have the
career i have today because i'm
because i learned how to cold so the one
other thing that i would tell my 20 year
old self
look i own seven businesses
and i would not tell you i would not
tell the 20 year old grant
to go get six six businesses i would
tell him
to learn everything he can about real
estate everything
real estate is the business that's
allowed me to go
on these magnificent trips that i'm
taking my family on
i've been in business for myself for 30
years
okay six businesses do not
six businesses combined do not allow me
to go
on these trips it is the real estate by
and of itself
it's allowed me to take my wife and kids
employees partners friends on these
magnificent trips
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line
of the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
reading should not be your priority
learning should be your priority
there used to be only a small number of
ways to learn it used to only be
reading or maybe going to lectures and
learning from people but reading
was one of the fastest ways to learn
because you could take somebody's life
and in one book and that's the whole
thing all the lessons and here you go
chance to learn now though there's so
many different ways to learn
there's podcasts there's videos and so
you need to understand what is the best
way that you learn
reading does not have to be in your top
priority but learning
has to be the difference between where
you are today and where you will be in
five years
that growth will be in direct relation
to how much you learn how much you feed
this brain right here
with knowledge that shifts the way you
think but it doesn't have to come from
reading
so looking at my store as an example i
used to read all the time growing up i
used to read i'm
39 now so i used to read a lot growing
up it was the only way to learn and the
idea of being able to look at any famous
entrepreneur and look at their story and
how they got started
that was a lot of knowledge that that
allows you to step into somebody's world
right if you don't like your environment
you don't like the people around you you
don't want to become
your parents or the people in your
community you want something better you
want something bigger
then you need to start to surround
yourself with those people and reading
is a great way to step
into their world and so i used to read
every single week
not quite every day but almost i was
reading a lot i was voracious
but as soon as video came out i quickly
shifted
i would much rather watch a video than
read a book
i just learn better that way i would
much rather have
an elon musk video watch him and see him
tell his story and look at the body
language
than i would reading a book about
somebody else telling elon musk's story
that's me that's how i learn i listen to
zero podcasts
because auditory is the slowest way for
me to learn
if it was the only way if the only way
to learn was to listen to podcasts and i
would be all over it and i would force
myself to do it
because i love learning but because
there's so many different options and i
love video first
i default to learning through video like
this
videos like this on my multiple channels
and so video is by far number one for me
and i consume video pretty much every
single day of my life
number two would be reading and a huge
drop down to number two i'll read maybe
three to four books a year
and then number three would be auditory
which would be podcasts and i
consume zero podcasts i don't know that
i've listened to an entire podcast
all the way through it would have to be
some person that i can't find the video
or book on and the only information the
only way to get it is to listen to a
podcast
so the point of all this is not to slam
on podcasts or audiobooks i have my own
audio
book i read it myself it's fire if you
love learning from auditory then you
should go and go all in on that
the point is to prioritize learning you
need to have learning as a regular part
of your life if you do not learn
consistently then you will end up in the
same spot you are right you will be in
the same spot you are
in five years if you do not learn but
it's figuring out where you learn best
and going all in on that strategy so
what's the best way for you to learn i'm
going to give you a three-step process
that i think will help
step number one is who do you want to
learn from you want to learn from people
who've done more than you have in a
certain field or industry right if you
want to learn to be a better parent
a better husband a better wife a better
entrepreneur a better salesperson a
better marketer
who who's the person that you want to
learn from and it doesn't mean you have
to become that person
the goal isn't to be the next steve jobs
is to learn one thing from steve jobs
that makes you
a better version of you so who is the
person that you most want to learn from
right now
step number two is identify how do you
learn best how do you
how do you learn best i don't care what
other people are doing do you learn best
through videos do you learn best through
reading or do you learn best through
auditory
listening to podcasts and audio books
how do you learn best
and then number three is create a
regular learning schedule if you know
who you want to learn from the types of
people and you know your learning style
then what's your
ongoing regular learning schedule that
has to be in your week
every single week whether that's a daily
thing make whether you make that part of
your daily routine
i'm a big fan of that otherwise it's
gotta be somewhere in your week
you will never learn the material that
you want to learn you will never be able
to emulate and model somebody else's
success to turn you
into the best version of yourself if you
don't have that as a part of your
regular week
right your actions need to map to your
ambitions what's in your calendar
has to map to you accomplishing the
goals that you want if you just have
goals if you just want to learn
you want to become that person but it's
not in your schedule anywhere you're
never going to become it
i'm going to teach you a mindset hack
that if you can learn to apply
will help you eliminate your self-doubt
your fears your insecurities
and step forward confidently into
whatever situation you get yourself into
and it's this you teach yourself that
you can learn
anything you can learn anything you may
not have the answers right now you may
not know how to do the crazy thing that
you want to do you've got big goals big
big dreams big ambitions you want to do
something big that's why you're watching
this channel right you're part of
believe nation you want to do something
big with your life i love it
you don't know how to do it you teach
yourself i
can learn anything because what we often
struggle with is you want to do
something
you know you can't do it yet and then
you associate with
that i suck i can't do something so i
suck
and that attack on your self-worth
on your self-confidence on your
self-esteem prevents you from actually
going off and creating something amazing
right i think
i think you're a genius i think you have
michael jordan level talent at something
i believe that i don't just say it in
videos
i believe that that's true so whatever
you're stuck on
instead of making yourself feel like you
suck that you're not good enough that
you're not capable of it
understand that it's just a skill set
that's missing the difference between
where you're at right now
and where you want to be is the skills
that you acquire
and in the action that you're taking
you're willing to take action
problem is you probably don't have the
skills yet to be where you want to be
that's okay
you tell yourself i can learn anything
learning becomes your superpower
i had a guy on my instagram live not
that long ago
and he was talking about becoming a
digital marketer
and he was asking me what place do i
sign up for a degree for digital
marketing and is it worth getting a
degree for digital marketing because i
want to i want to be a digital marketer
i want to sell my digital marketing
services to
entrepreneurs there are some fields
where having a degree is really
important
digital marketing is not one of them
going to i don't even know if you can
get that in university but
going to take somebody's digital
marketing certification
is not going to be helpful for you in
terms of getting new clients you might
learn some new skills that you can use
to get new clients
but he was putting too much stock in the
paper his belief
was in the paper that because he was
going to get this certification that
says that he was a digital marketer
that that would help him get more
clients now if you're going to get
a law degree or an accounting degree or
something
official you know professionals then
great yes you can't become a lawyer
without going to law school
right but digital marketing if they're
teaching at a school
it's already outdated digital marketing
is changing on the fly i look at what
i'm doing on my youtube channel
if i was to teach a course at a youtube
conference a year ago it would be
different it's why
in my youtube growth boot camp i update
it constantly with the new things that
i'm learning because it changed from one
year ago
textbooks are written like two three
four sometimes five
six longer years ago so apply to digital
marketing it's already out of date
but the problem with the guy who called
into my ig live was
his faith his trust was in the paper
that having the paper having a degree
would help him get credibility
and close clients his trust your trust
your faith needs to be in yourself needs
to be in you and your ability to learn
not in your abilities that you have
right now because you don't
have the abilities yet to do the thing
that you want to do you're not
capable yet if you were capable you
would have done it you're not ready yet
that's okay
but you're able to learn you you
you can learn anything so whenever
you're
in fear and insecurity in doubt you're
not sure what to do
don't take it personally don't say i
suck as a human because i don't have
this skill set
you can learn anything remind yourself
of it and then you need to create a
customized program for you
you need to create your own university
your own learning program
so that every day you're slowly
acquiring
that skill that knowledge said that
you're missing it's why i created the
254 series
where every day for 254 days you get a
new video on a topic
that if you want more confidence if you
want more self love you want more
motivation you want to be a writer
we've got lots of different topics
there's hopefully something there for
you but
even though i mean i may not have made
it yet right i made a whole bunch and
they're free for you but if i didn't
make it you go make your own
my youtube channel is my own that every
day
i want more belief in my life and so i
created the channels for that
and hopefully that spreads and you guys
like it you're getting more belief with
every video too
but you need to create your own program
every day whatever the skill set is that
you want to learn
that is the only gap between where you
are and where you want to be
because you're willing to take action
you just don't have the skill sets yet
but you're willing to learn
and you're able to learn anything you
can learn
anything that needs to be on loop in
your head i can learn anything
i don't know how to do it yet but i can
learn anything
and then apply it so every day what are
you going to be learning
every day what video you're going to
watch what book you're going to read
what podcast you're going to listen to
how are you going to learn who you're
going to reach out to
who's done the thing that you want to do
and how can you learn from them and
apply it
every day it's there's never been more
information out there there's never been
more thought leaders experts people
who've succeeded sharing their tips
their advice their knowledge their
feedback
and you can start for free before you go
and hire somebody as a
as a coach or you drop thousands of
dollars on somebody's mastermind
consume their content for free youtube
videos are free
podcasts are free buy their book it's
gonna cost
20 bucks 25 bucks right invest small
make sure you're getting knowledge that
helps make sure you're getting knowledge
that when you apply it works
and then you can start spending more but
you need to see a return on investment
for every dollar you put in
for all the mentors that you pick your
time and the money that you're putting
in
you're a genius i i and i you know a
little frustrated
because i love you and i want to see you
win and i see so many talented people
and believe nation with great ideas
great ambition and great heart great
heart like you want to do great things
for the right reasons and serve the
world
you just haven't learned the skills yet
and so you remind yourself
i can learn anything whatever problem in
front of me right now
i don't have the skill sets yet then i
can learn anything the people who are
telling you that your idea
won't work are not the people whose life
that you want
so why are you listening to them your
uncle joe
your aunt susan the rest of your family
the people who you grew up with from
high school
look at their life look at their life
right now take away their words and what
they're telling you remove the emotion
from it
look at their life do you want a life
like theirs because their advice will
lead to a life like theirs
if not then you probably should be doing
the exact opposite of what they're
telling you to do
now i think there's two types of people
who will give you negative feedback you
got the haters
and then you got the people who are just
ignorant and there's a big difference
between those two
so let's start with the haters the
haters i call the little man the haters
their entire role in their life is to
bring other people down maybe they took
their shot this is actually quite
frequent they took their shot
they tried they didn't work they failed
and so now
nobody around them can be successful
they get their value they get their self
love
by destroying other people because it
makes them feel better about themselves
it's like watching some train wreck on
reality tv show
right watching relationships and lives
fall apart because it makes you feel
better about your life
you feel better about your life when you
see somebody else's life be a total mess
right those are the haters now how do
you deal with them
it starts by understanding that if you
believe like i believe that humans are
built to serve right people are built to
serve you want to do good
people are good right both of those
things humans are good and we're built
to serve
then what would get somebody who was
good and built to serve
to leave a nasty negative comment or to
tell you that you suck or your deal is
not going to work out
what would drive them to do it they
really hate their life
right like empathy is the first step
just feeling bad for them not not
sympathy in
in and using that as a negative against
them not saying well your life sucks so
i'm not gonna
that that's not gonna help anything it's
actual genuine empathy
if the highlight of somebody's day is
coming to this video and leaving a
negative comment
it's okay i feel bad for that person
if that's the highlight of your day then
you must be in a really rough spot if
you're
if you believe that people are good and
they're built to serve and so what that
does is remove the sting out of the
comment when somebody is
raging on you that that you suck and
that your idea is never going to work
having empathy to understand wow this
person is likely in a really tough spot
that removes the stinging of the words
and allows you to then be
more practical less emotional
to respond emotionally and feel like oh
my god maybe they're right maybe they
have a point maybe i do suck
say wait wait a minute wait a minute
this person they hate their life
why am i listening to them right just
like the wake up call
out of the the head game that you're in
listen to their advice so those are the
haters remove the sting and then allow
you to make a practical decision
the second part are the people who are
ignorant they're your friends your
family the people around you
who they actually love you right chances
are your parents love you
your mom probably loves you right most
moms love their kids
your parents probably love you so why
would they be telling you not to go do
something
why would they be telling you advice
against what you want to hear
because they grew up in a different era
your parents are pilgrims
your parents don't understand the world
that exists your parents don't
understand that
you can have a full-time business from
this it doesn't make sense
when your parents were your age they
couldn't do the things that you can do
so they want you to be successful the
people around you who love you
want you to be successful they have a
different definition of success
success to them looks different than it
does for you because they're from a
different era
and that's okay again starting point is
empathy
understand that these words that are
coming out of their mouth
is love they're trying to express love
they're concerned for you
they want you to win they just have a
different version of what winning looks
like
and so when you're dealing with with
parents or friends or family
chances are the thing that you're great
at michael jordan level talent the thing
that you want
is not the thing that your family does
and so it takes a lot of courage and
strength to say here's what my family
does here's what my community does
here's what my friends are doing
i want to be doing this that's hard that
takes a lot of strength and courage
and then these people they don't want to
see you go off and do that because they
want you to stay here they want you to
stay
in their community what does it say
about them if you're off doing something
else right it's their own fears and
insecurities
because if you go off and have success
over here it makes them feel bad about
themselves
they start to doubt themselves and what
they're doing they don't want to do that
so having empathy right understanding
that and then especially of dealing with
parents
i'm going harder on the parents because
i get so many entrepreneurs who are
who are asking me about how to deal with
my parents
when you are trying to pitch your idea
and say here's what i want to do
and you are absolutely convinced that
it's going to work guess what's going to
happen
your parents or the people who love you
will double down on why it's not the
thing to do
if you say i'm going to go be a youtuber
right
great i want to be a full-time youtuber
and you can say well look at all these
people who've had
successful careers as full-time
youtubers you go tell them that they
said that's crazy don't be a youtuber
you go get a job go be a lawyer like
that's the safe that's stable
go into real estate that's what you
should be doing don't don't go be a
youtuber that's crazy
the more certain you are in it the more
they're going to think you're crazy and
they're going to double down on it
the more you think of of course it's
going to work out what are you talking
about why don't you support me
right if you're fighting why don't you
love me why don't you support me why
don't you why don't you encourage me
look at all these people having success
of course i can do it what don't you
believe in me
the more you attack them and are certain
in your position
the more they're going to build up their
walls and be more certain their position
because they think this this person is
understand what's happening
this person is so blind how do you not
see this thing
on the other hand if you approached it
from a softer side if you said
listen i don't know if it's going to
work out i know a lot of people try
and don't work out in business a lot of
a lot of entrepreneurs never make it
i'm afraid that it won't work but i have
to try
i have to try because i know that if i
don't try i'm going to regret it i'm
going to get to the end of my life and
i'm going to regret not having taken my
shot
and i don't want to look back on my life
and say this was my moment to try
and i was too afraid i don't want to be
afraid
i would rather know and fail than not
know and i'm scared
i hope you can understand that and
support that
that's a lot easier for somebody to come
down and say
okay i understand you're not attacking
them
you're leaning on vulnerability and and
your fears and insecurities more than on
certainty that this is going to work and
it's likely going to lead to a much
healthier relationship and healthier
conversation
now it doesn't mean that they're
automatically going to accept you and
yes that's what you're going to do
and then you have to decide are you
going to live your life or your parents
version of your life
your family's version of your life your
community's version of your life when
you when you get to decide that it's
your life
when you're four years old you don't
have a choice right you do what your
parents tell you to do
when you become an adult though what is
it 14 is it 16 is it 20 is it
25 is it 32 are you gonna be 50 and
still doing what your parents want you
to do like at what at what age you get
to decide
you're gonna say this is my life and i'm
gonna i'm gonna live my life and if
people support me great and if not
i'm gonna be an army of one and i'm
gonna will it into existence
so if you're an entrepreneur doing crazy
amazing things you got this vision you
want to change the world you want to
serve you want to have an impact you
want to make money
you're going to be faced with a lot of
people who criticize you because you
want to disrupt the status quo and do
something different there's a lot of
people who don't want you to do
something different
they like the status quo they want you
to just fit inside the status quo
fit inside this perfect puzzle piece sit
in your box
and you're good to go right a lot of
people want that for you
and over that course of you building
your amazing dream business
you're going to get faced with both
kinds of people giving you negative
feedback
the haters and the people who are just
ignorant
and learning to start with empathy
understand where they're coming from
and then deal with it in a way that is
empowering using the strategies i gave
you
will give you more confidence and
courage and positivity
and energy and optimism to move forward
because you need it
because building a business is crazy
tough crazy hard
you need all the support you can get and
if at the end of the day you still have
nobody who supports you you can come on
back to believe nation
because we're here every day there's a
lot of love for me but also you guys
in the comments in the community you can
share your thoughts share what you're
going through
and chances are you have somebody who
will help you who will be a guiding
support who will listen to you and
support you as well
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free
and get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there